you're kind of implying that mathematics
it almost feels like a kind of weird
evolutionary tree that ultimately leads
back to some kind of ancestral
a few fundamental ideas that all are
just like
they're all somehow connected uh in that
sense do you think
uh math is fundamental to our universe
and we're just like
slowly trying to understand
these patterns or is is it is it
discovered
or is it just a little game that we play
yeah
amongst ourselves to try to fit little
patterns to the world
yeah that's the question right that's
the physicist question i mean i'm
probably i'm in the discovered camp
but i don't do theoretical physics so i
know they have a
they they feel like they have a stronger
claim to answering that question
but they don't come back to it
everything comes back to it i mean all
the physics
the fact that the universe is well okay
it's a complicated question so how how
often do you think
how deeply does this result describe the
fundamental reality of nature
so the the the reason i hesitated that
because it's something i'm
i taught this seminar and did a little
work on what are called biological
algorithms
so there's this notion of
so physicists used mathematics
to explain the universe right and it was
unreasonable that mathematics works so
well
you know all these differential
equations why does that explain
all we need to know about thermodynamics
and gravity and all these all these type
of things well there's this kind
there's this movement within the
intersection of computer science and
biology
this is kind of wolf ramyun i guess
really that uh
algorithms can be very explanatory right
like if you're trying to if you're
trying to explain parsimoniously
something about like an ant colony or
something like this you're not going to
ultimately it's not going to be
explained as an equation like a physics
equation it's going to be explained by
an algorithm so like this algorithm
run distributedly is going to explain
the behavior so
that's mathematical but not quite
mathematical but it is if you think
about an algorithm like a lambda
calculus which brings you back to the
the world of mathematics i'm thinking
out loud here but basically
abstract math is sort of like
unreasonably effective
at explaining a lot of things and that's
just what i feel like i glimpse i'm not
a
um not like a super well-known
theoretician i don't have really famous
results
so even as a sort of middling
you know career theoretician i keep
encountering this
where we think we're solving some
problem about computers and algorithms
and it's some much deeper underlying
math it's shannon but shannon is entropy
but entropy was really
you know goes all the way back to
whatever it was boiler all the way back
to looking at the early physics and
and it's anyways to me i think it's
amazing
yeah i mean but it could be the flip
side of that could be just our brains
draw so much pleasure from the
uh deriving generalized theories and
simplifying the universe
that would just naturally see that kind
of simplicity and everything
yeah so that's the whole you know newton
einstein right
so you can you can say this must be
right because it's so predictive
well it's not quite predictive because
mercury wobbles a little bit but i think
we have it set and then you turn out
no einstein and then and then you get
bore like no not einstein it's actually
statistical and yeah so that would say
it's hard to also know like where a
smooth analysis fits into all that
or a little bit of noi like you can say
something very clean
about a system and then a little bit of
noise
like the average case is actually very
different and so
yeah i mean that's where like the
quantum mechanics comes in it's like ugh
why does that have to be randomness in
this yeah i would have to do this
complex
statistics yeah yeah
so to be determined yeah that'll be my
next book that'd be ambitious
the fundamental the fundamental core of
reality
comma and some advice for being more
productive at work
you